Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to take these old low-quality
photos, and ask an AI what it thinks they
should look like.
And yes, we are going to see a restored version
of this photo of Einstein, and this one too.
And the results are absolutely amazing.
In fact, I could hardly believe some of the
results so I had to check them over and over
again.
So, what is the problem here?
Well, we have one input photo, which is a
blurry mess, and when we try to restore it
with a previous method, the output is…also
a blurry mess.
This was DFDNet, a research paper from 2020.
Surely, something better must be out there
by now.
And, yes there is!
This is GFP-GAN, a technique from 2021.
This is significantly better, but the hair
is full of artifacts, and the photo itself
is still not that sharp.
Now, have a look at this.
This is GPEN, also a paper from 2021, and
this is much better than its predecessors.
But if you think that this image has detail,
now have a look at the new technique.
Whoa, this is so much better.
The hair has tons of detail, the glasses finally
look right, and now that we are comparing
the two side by side, we see an interesting
effect.
The previous method created an idealized image
where a lot of wrinkles and other high-frequency
effects are now gone.
And believe it or not, this aspect of the
new AI is controllable.
I’ll tell you about it in a moment.
Now, this new technique is so good, we can
even use it on old photos, and get this, even
movies.
Due to copyright issues, I can only show you
still images from here, but I made sure to
put the full videos in the video description
so you Fellow Scholars can have a look.
I will note that I have found some temporal
coherence issues, in other words, some jumpy
behavior, but it was very mild.
I think many people wouldn’t even notice
that an AI restoration algorithm was at work
here.
And I know what you are waiting for.
Now, it’s Einstein time.
I will say in advance that we are going to
talk about what this new AI thinks Einstein
looked like.
We cannot be for sure.
Now hold on to your papers and let’s see.
Whoa.
This is incredible image restoration, and
the technique delivers amazingly well over
and over again.
Now, once again, we cannot say that this is
exactly what Einstein looked like, but I feel
like with every paper, we get closer and closer.
And here, I will try my best to show you the
strengths and weaknesses of this algorithm
so you can decide for yourself.
Now, I promised that we are going to talk
about identity preservation.
So let’s have a look together at this.
We can use this parameter before restoration,
this preserves the identity of the subject,
at the cost of some additional quality.
Or, if we are looking for a super-high quality
output, and are okay with the results not
looking like exactly the same person, we can
also do this.
Yes, this gives us a super-high quality image,
but the magnitude of the changes can be such
that we get a different person.
Now, my first thought was that well, what
is the point of this?
Why would anyone use this?
But then it struck me.
Are you thinking what I am thinking?
Look!
Got it?
We can use this on synthetic characters created
by an AI.
These are sometimes highly imperfect images,
and in this case, we can supposedly get a
super high quality version of this human.
Let’s see!
Wow, now that’s what I call a huge difference.
Restoration happened, the facial features
are a little different, but this is a synthetic
character, in this case, we might decide that
we don’t mind this tradeoff so much.
Now, for the case when we pull the slider
to the right to have slightly lower quality,
but preserve the identity of the image better.
This is obviously super useful.
However, how do we know if these results are
truly good?
We cannot compare this with high-fidelity
photos of Einstein, the whole point of this
technique is that such high-quality photos
don’t exist.
Well, one way is to take an image of someone
we know, delete parts of it, have it restore
it, and compare to the original.
Now, there will be some failure cases from
previous techniques that look a tiny bit frightening,
so if you are not ready for that, stop the
video now.
Otherwise, let’s see.
Whoa.
To say that some of these previous methods
were not so good at this would be an understatement.
Now let’s see the new technique.
Wow!
This is so far beyond the previous techniques,
it is hard to believe that such progress can
be made in just one paper.
But, if we take the time to look through the
results, it delivers over and over again.
And at this point, there is no doubt in my
mind that we are going to see people who are
not with us anymore in all their glory on
our screens.
That is incredible.
So, how long do we have to wait for such an
image?
Well, not long at all.
This new technique can pull this off not in
minutes, and not even in seconds.
It does this 14 times every second.
Wow.
But you know what?
I have good news - you Fellow Scholars can
try it right now online!
Let the experiments begin!
So, what do you think?
Whose image would you like to restore?
Isaac Asimov anyone?
Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for
your generous support, and I'll see you next
time!